carrots are great they're crunchy
beautiful sweet loaded with vitamins but
can they really help you see better
eating carrots improves your vision true
or false
carrots are full of beta-carotene which
your body converts into vitamin A
vitamin A is great for your eyes it can
help prevent cataracts and support
normal eye function like being able to
adjust your eyes when you walk into a
dark room versus a bright room the thing
is carrots aren't the only vegetables
full of molecules that your body can
convert into vitamin A all kinds of
greens Tomatoes beets they all have
plenty of vitamin A precursors not to
mention a ton of other valuable vitamins
as well so there's really nothing
exclusively beneficial about eating
carrots to support healthy eyes and
while vitamin A may be good for your
eyes overall it can't correct or improve
your vision specifically that is it
can't actually change how in or out of
focus certain things appear in your line
of sight if you're near or farsighted
eating all the carrots in the world
isn't going to get you any closer to
20/20 so put your glasses back on
because this food myth it's false but
you should still eat your veggies